♪ ♪
>> Sean: REPUBLICAN
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY TONIGHT IS
RAISING SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE RECORD OF BIDEN'S
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE
JUDGE BROWN JACKSON.
ACCORDING TO WHAT HE CALLS AN
ALARMING PATTERN OF LENIENT
TREATMENT TOWARDS SEX OFFENDERS,
FOR EXAMPLE, AS HE WRITES, "AS A
MEMBER OF THE U.S. SENTENCING
COMMISSION, JUDGE JACKSON
ADVOCATED FOR DRASTIC CHANGE IN
HOW THE LAW TREATS SEX OFFENDERS
BY ELIMINATING EXISTING
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES FOR
CHILD" AND CITING ONE CASE WHERE
THE SENTENCING GUIDELINES CALLED
FOR A SENTENCE OF UP TO TEN
YEARS IN PRISON BUT
JUDGE JACKSON SENTENCED THE
PERPETRATOR TO ONLY THREE MONTHS
BEHIND BARS.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
JEN PSAKI SAID THAT THE
CRITICISM WAS TAKEN OUT OF
CONTEXT AT SOME OF THE REMARKS
WERE SOMETHING A WITNESS SAID IN
ORDER TO ASK A QUESTION.
AND THAT'S NOT ALL BECAUSE WE
ARE ALSO LEARNING THAT BIDEN'S
NOMINEE PRAISED THE DISCREDITED
1619 PROJECT IN AN MLK DAY
SPEECH BACK IN 2020.
CONFIRMATION HEARINGS ARE
EXPECTED TO BEGIN ON MONDAY.
HERE TO EXPLAIN MORE, MISSOURI
REPUBLICAN SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY.
SENATOR, TELL EVERYBODY WHAT YOU
FOUND.
>> WELL, WHAT I FOUND, SEAN, IS
A PATTERN HERE OF TREATING
SEX OFFENDERS LENIENTLY.
THOSE WHO HAVE GONE AFTER
CHILDREN.
I THINK WE HAVE A BASIC QUESTION
TO ASK.
ARE WE GOING TO GET A JUDGE HERE
WAS GOING TO PROTECT CHILDREN OR
WHO'S GOING TO PROTECT CHILD
PREDATORS?
IT'S A SIMPLE QUESTION, ONE I
THINK THAT EVERY PARENT IN
AMERICA WOULD LIKE ANSWERED BUT
IT'S ONE OF THE WHITE HOUSE
DOESN'T WANT TO ANSWER AND SO
FAR JUDGE JACKSON DOESN'T WANT
TO ANSWER IT.
TOTAL RADIO SILENCE FROM HER AND
IF YOU LOOK AT HER RECORD, WHICH
YOU SEE IS THIS IS SOMEONE WHO O
IS CONSISTENTLY LET PREDATORS
OFF THE HOOK FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED.
SHE IS CONSISTENTLY THEM LENIENT
SENTENCES, SLAPS ON THE WRIST.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO WAS RAISED
THE QUESTION WHETHER REGISTRIES
ARE UNCONSTITUTIONAL, WHETHER
NOTIFYING PARENTS WHEN THERE'S
AN OFFENDER IN THE AREA IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
SEE SHOULD -- SHE SUGGESTED ALL
OF THAT.
THIS IS VERY TROUBLING, WE NEED
TO GET THE ANSWERS.
>> Sean: YOU SAY THIS CAME
BOTH AS A JUDGE AND A
POLICYMAKER, MEANING HER
BACKGROUND, AND ARE CONCERNED
THAT THIS IS A RECORD THAT WILL
ENDANGER CHILDREN AND YOU CITE
OTHER CASES.
I MEAN, HOW DO SOMEBODY FACING A
10-YEAR SENTENCE FOR SOMETHING
THIS SERIOUS ONLY GET THREE
MONTHS IN PRISON?
>> YEAH, THAT'S THE PROBLEM,
SEAN.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT SHE'S DONE
AS A JUDGE ON THE BENCH WHEN SHE
HAD THE CHANCE TO PUT AWAY CHILD
PREDATORS OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE CASES,
SHE CHOSE TO GIVE THEM THE
LATEST SENTENCE POSSIBLE IN CASE
AFTER CASE.
YOU MENTIONED ONE, THE
GUIDELINES RECOMMENDED TEN
YEARS.
SHE GAVE HIM THREE MONTHS.
AND WE COULD GO ON AND ON.
THE PROBLEM IS I HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO FIND A SINGLE CASE WHERE
SHE HAS HAD AN OFFENDER IN FRONT
OF HER WHERE SHE HASN'T GIVEN
HIM THE MOST LENIENT SENTENCE
SHE POSSIBLY COULD.
AND AGAIN, THIS IS SOMEONE SINCE
LAW SCHOOL WHO HAS BEEN SAYING
THAT THE OFFENDER REGISTRIES MAY
BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL, THAT
NOTIFYING PARENTS ABOUT
OFFENDERS IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
MAY BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND WHO
VOTED AS A MEMBER OF THE U.S.
FENTON'S AND COMMISSION, SHE
VOTED TO GET RID OF THE
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES, SO
THIS IS A LONG PATTERN.
IT STRETCHES OVER MANY YEARS AND
WE NEED TO GET ANSWERS ON THIS.
>> Sean: SENATOR, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT FOR EXAMPLE, YOU READ
ABOUT PRISONS AND TWO THINGS
THEY CONSISTENTLY PRISONERS
DON'T LIKE THAT I HEAR ABOUT.
ONE, THEY DON'T LIKE RATS,
PEOPLE THAT TELL ANOTHER PEOPLE
TO CUT DEALS TO MAKE THEIR LIFE
EASIER, AND THE SECOND THING IS
THOSE THAT ARE PREDATORS AGAINST
CHILDREN.
I CAN'T THINK OF A SINGLE
LOGICAL REASON WHY THERE'S
LENIENCY ON THIS ISSUE
CONSIDERING WE'RE TALKING BUT
THE MOST INNOCENT PEOPLE IN
SOCIETY.
HAVE YOU COME TO ANY CONCLUSION
AS TO WHY THIS IS?
>> I CAN'T FIGURE IT OUT, SEAN,
AND THIS IS WHAT WE NEED TO HEAR
FROM HER ON.
SHE'S REALLY GOING TO HAVE TO
TELL US.
THIS IS WHY HER HEARINGS ARE SO
IMPORTANT.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHY DID SHE GIVE
THESE OFFENDERS THESE LIGHT
SENTENCES.
WHY DID SHE VOTE TO GET RID OF
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES, THE
EXISTING ONES, ANYWAY.
WHY DID SHE SAY WAY BACK AS
EARLY AS LAW SCHOOL, WHY WAS SHE
SAYING THAT MAYBE THESE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRIES AND
OTHER PROTECTIVE MEASURES WERE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL?
THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT SHE'S
GOING TO NEED TO ANSWER AND I
THINK EVERY PARENT IN AMERICA IS
GOING TO WANT TO KNOW THE
ANSWERS BECAUSE THIS IS A
LIFETIME APPOINTMENT TO THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HERE.
SHE COULD BE RULING ON THESE
CASES AND WE NEED TO KNOW.
>> Sean: WE NEED TO KNOW --
REAL QUICK, YOUR FELLOW
REPUBLICANS, DO THEY SHARE YOUR
CONCERN?
TEN SECONDS.
>> YOU KNOW, I HOPE